mario paul et ses quartiers dévastés où
les maisons sont anéanties par les bons
ces images datent de mercredi lorsque la
ville était déjà assiégé par l'armée
russe ici les habitants vivent sous les
bombes et manquent de tout eau
nourriture
électricité les troupes russes ont créé
un véritable blocus
nous sommes à nouveau sans électricité
nous sommes à nouveau sans eau nous
sommes toujours sans chauffage
objectif s'emparer de cette ville
portuaire du sud est de l'ukraine après
avoir pris personne mercredi avec mario
poehl la crim est annexée par la russie
en 2014 et le dombass ou règne les
forces pro russes seraient reliés et
constituerait tout un territoire sous
occupation russe cette jonction
permettrait aussi à moscou le
regroupement de ses troupes venues de
crimée et celle des territoires
pro-russes la russie prendrait alors le
contrôle total de la mer d'azov